hey guys justin hey Walt here with a
gamespot news update just as the Wii U
is meeting with some widespread success
Miyamoto has stated that the company has
already hard at work on their next round
of consoles although it shouldn't come
as a surprise that Nintendo is working
on a successor to the wii u it is
unusual for an executive to talk about a
new console so early in the life cycle
of the current one Miyamoto said that
Nintendo is in the formative stage of
designing new hardware and suggested
that preliminary work is underway on
more than one system he said for the
time being our focus is on the wii u
hardware but Nintendo as a whole has
groups working on ideas for new hardware
systems while we're busy working on
software for the Wii U we have
production lines that are working on
ideas for what the next system might be
this follows a recent report that
electronics firm sharp will provide a
free-form display for Nintendo to use in
their next handheld device the new
screens can be created in custom shapes
and the report says nintendo is
considering creating a hole in the
center of the display making a doughnut
shape with a new 3ds doin store shelves
in the west in early 2015 it's unlikely
that we'll see new hardware anytime soon
but as those details emerge be sure to
stay tuned to gamespot com / news